welcome back to grammar and filter taste
by me Josh Smith and say we don't buy
now hello everyone how are you I'm great
great to see you
[Music]
so you out there on the riser can't wait
yeah I'm excited about this one I was
excited about the first one but now that
I have lived with my new solo life for a
little bit I feel more comfortable I'm
feeling more confident when I walk into
the studio it could all go tits up and
it could be game over but I feel like
I've written my best stuff and I'm just
excited now what do you think you've
learned about yourself from the first
album
to the second out there and I've made
the first album I was probably 20 to 22
or 3 maybe 23 and the gap between 23 and
26 is a lot more you look completely
different I feel hopefully I can hold on
to the babyface for a little bit but
like you know you feel like amateur a
lot can you think the specific turning
point in your like journey of
self-discovery which is such a big term
that has a big one I feel like in the
last one even in the last 18 months two
years haven't you know a relationship
and then that end and then writing about
that and when it being like quite raw I
can learn to love myself off the back of
that even the type of album I wrote
usually I would have written like a
quite selfish like if I sit down and
write a ballad it's gonna be sad and
it's gonna be about me you know what I
mean when I wrote that when I started to
come up with the concept for this album
I was thinking you know about all the
different aspects of that breakup from
other people's views from the other
person's view the different phases of
through that relationship whereas I
wouldn't have done that before you know
I've learned a lot
I bought myself off the back of that
relationship and I feel like the last 18
months has really changed me as a person
I think yeah I feel like I'm a bit more
prepared for life yeah you have so much
intense public scrutiny on you all the
time yeah you can pick up papers read
stories about yourself most of it not
true all the time yeah so when it comes
to actually being a songwriter like
yourself because you are very personal
on
right how difficult is that for you to
marry the two together to keep something
back for yourself but then also be very
truthful yeah I try to be as honest as I
can
sometimes you nearly not for anyone else
sometimes like I find myself sitting
there can I say that or should I not
because you're actually not thinking
about their coming out at the time when
you're so you're sitting there right now
you're thinking about am I ready to say
that you know and so you have to kind of
push yourself and but when you do you it
feels more rewarding and you clears that
toilet in your head and I'm lucky that
I've got that vehicle son right and as a
vehicle to like clear the head the
public and you know parts of the media
would like want to know who the songs
about that's the main thing but that's a
flash in the pan that story's out the
window yeah five minutes and everyone
goes oh that songs about that person
it's just more to the game of trying to
figure out who it is
but then as a songwriter the best fit
thing for me is when I play a show and I
play a ballad or and an honest one and I
look into the crowd and I see tears
rolling down faces they're not crying
because of who I wrote the song about
the crane ik cuz they've related it back
to something in their lives which is for
me is the best thing distort the like
who's the song about is the flash in the
pan it's over in five minutes and I
won't be telling anyone anyway but the
real stuff is when people have lived
with the songs and connected with them
in that way and that's that's why I like
tried to be as honest as I can because
need people to relate because in that
sense it's not even about someone else's
about you yeah cuz you happen on this in
the same personal journey because I was
actually thinking about this earlier
because I've never actually even thought
about this fact about you cuz you've
been in one direction he came on
x-factor so you've been kind of in like
our cultural eyes for such a long time
yeah yeah
but then actually just fought today you
were actually a 16 year old boy he like
moved away from home yeah and you were
with these other guys but basically on
your own in the sense yes what was that
like for you
all the parents had one thing in common
in that band was that they all said that
we just went through the addition never
came home
which is true you know I moved country
at 16 I mean to go on to do what I did
was pretty pretty amazing what at the
time was a cool yesterday I was in
school yeah in a small town of about
20,000 people and now I'm living in
London in a band and mean in hindsight
you know went on to do what I did but at
the time it was all a bit like their
crazy
how did you manage growing up in that
public eye how difficult was that for
you to be fair we had each other and I
don't think people realize the power of
that actually you know you see solo
stars and like I what Justin Bieber's
new docu-series and you can see you know
and no guy you know quite well and you
know you know how it affected him and
people didn't realize just the pressure
he was under or things like that I can
relate to that 100% but we were always
lucky that we we had each other I mean
he had his manager and security guy we
had our manager and our security team
and with people that we all tied each
other and each other to share the
experience with and and you know I
always I always felt sorry for Justin in
that in that respect
we came from simple backgrounds but we
are you know I think we had that in
common and it helped along the way so
when it was all going on around us we
were just gonna be like it or let the
bubble up chatting about it about how
crazy it is and couldn't believe where
we were all the time we never really
seen her side of us like these big
celebrities I think that was more of a
looking in third thing we were just
taking this little fish bowl yeah having
a great time and all the madness was
going on around us and then when you
came to being a solo artist
you're out there on your own yeah how
difficult was that for you to establish
your own identity away from that group
and create your own identity away from
it like what was that experience like
and I was lucky because I knew I mean I
like I'll never be complaining about
didn't one day tag following me around
absolutely yeah but then I was lucky I
always knew how my album would sound
like I know what I meant to I listen to
the same music a lot at the time same
styles of music and
I always kind of had a feeling if I was
to make it out on my own how it would
sound just having that was half you know
half the math if you like I think it's
why you're then also doing this putting
yourself out there a time where social
media is completely overwhelming over
these lives for the good for the bad how
do you cope with the negative side of
social media what has your experience of
the negative side station maybe been
like personally I'm quite thick skinned
and I don't really like I just know that
it's some person bored off their head at
home just keyboard warriors we always
say it's just it feels like the
vulnerable people I hate watching and
like vulnerable people being taken down
by Cameron Warriors and I all I actually
I'm always tweeting about about how I
think it's just ridiculous how people
can just say what they want and to each
other because if I just walk down Oxford
Street and just shout with someone and
abused people like to do an online I'd
probably be arrested
yeah so that's where I stand or not
seems to be a bit kinder in that said
yeah so much time is well talking about
the downsides of social media as well
but there's so many positives I thought
you were saying as well because you have
this amazing fandom that is that she
supported you throughout I always think
that how big one direction would have
been if we didn't have it there's like I
mean the Beatles were a different story
because they did all they took over the
globe but note that like a newspaper you
know we have we were we came out with
this narrative ourselves and basically
like Justin Bieber and Taylor Swift and
stuff like that at the start of Twitter
and things like that you just we had
that as our vehicle to promote ourselves
and stuff like that acne I think you
know famous people and became more
accessible because you can literally
tweet the funds we have full-on chats
there on a daily basis and that's what
it's great for I can chat or a to them
and like I consider myself to quite like
a happy person and I don't go I would
never like say to you Oh your hair looks
crap your shirt you know I'm actually
told you it's gonna bite into trousers
yeah whatever say that but some people
feel that they're all it's okay to do
when they have their phone in their hand
I mean the quicker we can stop that the
better do you find it quite constricting
feeling that people have this
accessibility ta I think I disturbed I
struggled with it because it was 1718 I
didn't understand it I was like what's
all this madness and rightly so but now
over the years you know I mean it's like
we're talking about it today it's like
10 years
you know since all of this kicked off
its yeah and so yeah I think I'm fine
with it now I've got a good balance good
I've got a great relationship with the
fans I think I think they'd agree and
yeah I'm fine with what I give away and
what yeah I think they're fine with it
too
how do you work on your mental
well-being in that sense I don't know I
tried it personally I tried to live as a
normal life as I can I think that's
helped I mean it sounds ridiculous that
I even say this it makes me sound like
I'm crazy or so but I'll go on the boss
or the tube or the shop yeah you rat
like normal stuff which sounds like yeah
obviously you're doing that because
you're human but something there was
that was stuff that I couldn't do it
before you know so and hanger Oh mate
and be really Irish abode and reserved
and keep myself to myself and as I said
when work turns and and full of steam
head but I think having to not having
the normal life and having the friends I
have I think it's been huge for me
big time I think it's great when people
start talking about their their
struggles or
you know the biggest stars in the world
are saying that you know we're not
working for human yeah I think society
is put a Sun like it like it
pedestal that were above everyone else
the truth is were just really normal
people you do a crazily abnormal job the
more the quicker we can level that out I
think you know the more human we making
because just automatically well it's
amazing when you do see that human side
of an artist you know like he really is
talking about her Tourette's or some
smiie you know besides for whatever yeah
we all we all have normal issues that
can you know really connect with people
who have the same sometimes are like oh
really overthink something I'm not like
generally NOT an over-thinker
but if I feel like it's gonna affect me
in some way like I'll really like think
about it for a long time like a couple
of days yes cats I'm thinking about that
and yeah but for the most part I'm like
I'm quite those anomie not quite level
and don't let too much faze me but if
the odd one pops up you're like it gets
you
yeah like anything we all I love that
this year we just don't want finally if
you could sit the you down because we're
just saying it's been ten years since
you first burst onto into our lives
basically what would you say if you
could sit the person that started out
ten years ago and I was that person
right here right now what would you want
to say to him what advice would you want
to give him keep smiling because there's
one thing like people always say it to
me I see what you always look like
you're enjoying yourself
that's what people always said to me
like you oh you already wonder it was
like yeah I can tell he was in enjoy
himself that's the way it should be his
if like I literally had dreams and stood
in mirrors and there's pictures of me at
three years of age we could terrace and
microphones on my hand showing off you
know that fellas good you know that's
the guy who dreamt of doing the job that
I do now so the longer I can keep that
in my head
it the better but yeah we just say get
ready cuz it's going to be wild do you
still feel like you're doing it for that
little kid that with salt
singing Sonora well congrats you've
slayed it you gonna slay it again with
the new album grats thank you very much
thanks so much thank you
[Music]